hey there my name is bradley knapp and i
am one of the product managers here at
ibm cloud
and we've come together today to talk
about what is a virtual server
and before we get into the video i do
want to encourage you please do like and
subscribe so you can get updates
whenever we do new videos like this in
the future
but with that let's go ahead and get in
what is a virtual server
you see it everywhere everyone talks
about it and if you don't know
that's okay because the tech press as a
rule makes an assumption
that everyone has a baseline of
knowledge that is as old as theirs is
and the folks that have been in the tech
press have been there for at least 10
years they've been there for 15 years
and so when you start out in your career
in tech you don't know the answers to
all these questions
and there's nothing wrong with that it's
a perfectly legitimate question
and it's one that we want to help you
out with so if we think about
hardware in a data center in your house
in your car
but physical hardware as a general rule
a computer is a box
right it's a physical box and inside
that physical box
you're going to have one or more cpus
that does compute you're going to have
some amount of ram
that does storage i guess we could label
these right cpu
ram and that storage is directly
attached to the cpu right the ram
is attached to the cpu so it's very
close it's for
the actual operation of the machine and
then you're going to have
network right because we're talking
about virtual servers
in cloud so network is important that is
how
the box talks to everything else and
then you're going to have
traditional storage i'm going to put
traditional storage over here for a
moment
because traditional storage can go
inside the server
or it can be out on its own but either
way those are kind of your four
fundamental building blocks so
a virtual server is a virtual compute
virtual ram virtual network virtual
storage
but it's presented in a way that it acts
like a server does
so if we consider a physical server
a to be a physical device you can put
your hands around
what a virtual server does is it takes
this physical host
and it divides it up into slices
right you've got slice one slice two
slice three slice form
your slices take all of the aggregate
resources
on the physical server and they present
just a little bit
now you don't have to do it that way if
instead of these little bitty slices
you want a great big huge slice and then
you want to fill the box up with a
little slice at the end
that's fine too but at the end of the
day a virtual server
is part of a physical server that you
get access to
and inside that virtual server or that
vsi
you are going to have compute you're
going to have ram
you're going to have network and you're
going to have storage
and it is presented to you to the user
to the consumer
just like a physical box would be but
because it's virtualized that
virtualization what that means is that
we're
taking and dividing these up we can
scale these resources
up and down so if you need a lot of
compute in just a little bit of ram
that's fine there's no problem with that
we can build the virtual server that way
if you need a little bit of compute and
a little bit of ram but a lot of network
right like it's running a website where
you're constantly sending data out
that's fine we can scale a virtual
server that way each of these metrics is
independently scalable so you can have a
little bit of compute a little bit of
ram a little bit of network and a ton of
storage
that's fine because again a virtual
server is designed
to solve whatever your specific needs
are
not the needs of the people who build
the box
and so why is this important well
as time has gone on and very
specifically over the last 10 years
our physical server boxes right the
physical boxes that go into the data
center have gotten
more and more and more powerful and that
power is great
but single workloads can't take
advantage of it
so using my example before just a normal
basic web server right a normal basic
web server might need
four vcpus for cpus it might need
64 gigabytes of ram it might need
a one gigabit network connection and it
might need
i don't know 250 gigabytes of storage
well a physical server that meets those
requirements
takes up a lot of space in a data center
right because our data center
if you go in there and you've got a data
center rack right i've got my rack here
and the racks have shelves and the
shelves are one utah
two utah four utah eight utah
you know the smallest unit is
a 1u now there are half you and you can
take one you and make it into three
servers but
just for our purposes let's call it a
physical slot in the data center rack
one you well this virtual server
if we were to put it in a physical
server would need that whole view of
space
that's not space efficient it's not
power efficient it's not
floor print efficient and it's bad for
general efficiency not just of compute
but it's not great for the environment
either
so we want to drive density so what you
do is you take that physical box that
takes up that same
one u of space right so one u
so we're gonna have a physical box that
takes up one u of space but we're gonna
make it
super powerful so that it can hold
50 of these virtual servers because we
have the ability to do that
with the advances in computing
technology we can pack
50 virtual servers of our little web
server
into one you space this is a great thing
it drives down the cost
because these servers if i can put 50 of
them on one physical box
the cost for my physical box over here i
divide up 50 ways
makes it much less expensive for you and
it makes the compute resources that
previously you'd have to go out rent a
data center space get the power into it
bring the network in
now you don't have to do that anymore
the cloud provider takes care of all of
that for you
and all you care about is that you're
going to have your one little vsi over
here that's going to cost you
20 cents an hour so that's the beauty of
a virtual server that's
how they work now obviously we didn't
get into the great fine
technical details if you'd like to know
more about that please do you know drop
us a note let us know we're happy to
give you
more information but that's a virtual
server that's how they work and that's
why they're important
thank you so much for stopping by today
if you like this video and you'd like to
see more like it
please do like and subscribe below if
you have questions please drop them in
the comments below
and we'll try to answer them for you and
if you'd like to learn more
please check out our webpage at the link
in the description or reach out to your
ibm sales team
or ibm business partner